it's a clear winter's day on Croatia's
adriatic coast perfect weather for tiana
voucher to go dolphin watching the
waters here are ideal for the marine
mammals it's just a matter of knowing
where to look their home range is pretty
wide so there's not like you know just
one place
after a short time scanning the sea we
spot them dolphins our guides tell us
that the dolphins and their habitat are
seriously under threat
the Croatian government has been heavily
lobbied by the oil and gas industry
there have been all refineries on the
coast for decades but now the government
wants to go one step further and permit
offshore drilling complete with
platforms just off the picturesque
coastline and this is the vessel that
will decide where the northern explorer
the British Norwegian company spectrum
is using it to conduct seismic surveys
of the adriatic sea bed it's in
september with what's known as an airgun
the dolphin specialists have been
monitoring the prospecting and are
concerned about the effects of these
sonic blasts seismic surveys are using
these arrays of air guns to produce
highly intense sound underwater with
these sounds that reflects on the
seafloor they get the information about
the structure of the seafloor and it is
this information is used by gas and oil
companies to understand eventually where
to build their platforms the head
researcher of the Adriatic dolphin
project is convinced that Croatia is
breaking EU laws by not conducting a
study of the environmental impact of the
oil survey now that we entered the
European Union because we obviously
didn't obey the commitments they drank
the air gun both through the internet
the northern explorer is heading north
the owners don't want us filming on
board so there's only one way to get a
closer look
we head out to record the first such
aerial footage of the northern Explorer
at work dragging its sonic gun array
across the Adriatic far from the public
gaze this ship is mapping out where the
best oil and gas reserves are the
mission is said to cost almost 8 million
euros but the project was awarded
without a legal bidding procedure
probably in violation of EU laws the
surveying company won't say who's paying
for it and neither will Croatia's
economics Minister yeah I have names but
I don't want to share that with you
what's that because I don't know about
the contracts that they sign it maybe
something is confident the government
says the drilling is in Croatia's
interests
I expect that Croatia will be the
country who will selling the gas who the
industry of Croatia will have the
cheaper gas in the region because if you
have it fine times more gas than it
territory then you need it Croatia has
been battling an economic recession for
five years joining the EU in the summer
of 2013 is not provided the hoped-for
boost but on the adriatic coast which is
dependent on tourism many people fear
the oil and gas lobbies verum fishes
Croatia's best known environmentalist we
meet him along with the latest addition
to his family rocky a young deer he
nursed back to health after it was hit
by a car
fish it says the way to nurse Croatia's
economy back to health is not with a
rush to drill for oil and gas without
any public debate without any tender
it's not allowed it's not illegal so I
must understand how his philosophy or
out the people in governments now
function you know you gave us power so
via Duke we control everything
the campaigner warns that careless
development of the coastline could cause
serious damage
we can be very afraid that we can have
disaster them the threat of oil spills
and these pristine waters is just one of
the dangers the researchers at the
Adriatic dolphin project say there's a
more immediate threat the surveying and
drilling activities themselves are
changing the environment soon there will
be no more dolphins in the area with its
push for oil and gas Croatia
could jeopardize its greatest resource
one of the most beautiful coastlines in
the eastern Mediterranean